the reason why certain things are
classic because it's able to trigger a
memory let's take 1982 for instance if
you just say 1982 instantly all I think
about is the purple hue used on the
cover of princes 1999 album this 1982
said technology was just coming into
bloom and there were you know new
synthesizers that o-over him
synthesizer in the linndrum the roger
linndrum to which prince was using a
whole nother level that no one else was
even thinking about so that November day
that I decided to take my monthly lunch
card money to buy a record then I wasn't
allowed to buy sneaked it at home under
my sweater and listening to it at low
volume obsessively for like three months
before my mom discovered it to throw it
away and there was just a magical period
of discovery of new music of new sounds